wir haben miteinander beschlossen dass
die im verordnung der länder bis zum 10
januar gelten werden also dann erst
einmal aber das ziel bleibt eben die
inzidenz runterzubringen das heißt wie
es anfang januar weitergeht können wir
heute noch nicht sagen sondern hängt
dann von den ergebnissen ab die wir
erreichen
wir bleiben bei den persönlichen
kontakten dabei dass freunde verwandte
und bekannte sich treffen können mit
maximal fünf personen und zwei haus
ständen und es gibt nur über die
weihnachtstage von 24 bis 26
dezember davon eine ausnahme nicht aber
zu silvester und neujahr
diese ausnahme heißt dass man über den
eigenen hausstand hinaus noch vier
weitere personen einladen kann
und zwar aus dem engsten familienkreis
also ehegatten lebenspartner partner
oder verwandte der geraden geliebt linie
das in eltern und geschwister und eltern
und kinder sowie auch für geschwister
gilt das aber es wird an alle
bürgerinnen und bürger appelliert wenn
sie andere haus stände aus der familie
zu weihnachten zu sich einladen
wann immer möglich die kontakte sieben
tage vorher zu reduzieren also eine
schutz woche einzulegen
so lässt auch neuer also die normalen
kontakt beschränkungen keine
sonderregeln wir werden ab mittwoch ab
dem 16 dezember in einzelhandel
schließen und nur noch für lebensmittel
und ähnliche dringende waren des
täglichen bedarfs offen halten es wird
auch darauf geachtet dass der verkauf
von nicht lebensmittelprodukten im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel nicht
ausgeweitet wird und es gibt ein verbot
des verkaufs von pyrotechnik vor
silvester das wird vom
bundesinnenministerium per verordnung
sichergestellt mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht
hier abonnieren